radish in vancouver
canada radish i gotta just be obvious
man as a guy whose last name rhymes with
the lunch meat
i had the childhood man is your real
name radish or is that just what they
call you uh
that's just what they call me well from
one fellow
food nickname to the other it's good to
talk to you man
how are you i'm good thank you so much
for taking my call
you bet how can i help okay so i've been
listening to the show for a while and
one thing i've noticed is quite a few of
the callers are having some kind of
struggle or issue in like their marriage
so i'm calling because my girlfriend and
i have been dating for about five months
i i love her so much and i'm pretty sure
she's like the one for me
so i'm wondering what we can do now so
that
we are prepared to have like a strong
and connected and healthy
marriage in the future well good for you
man uh that's awesome that you are
thinking that way and i appreciate the
the uplifting call so i'm gonna start
your uplifting answer with a
negative are you ready okay there's no
such thing as the one
doesn't exist not real okay yeah yeah i
did you know i was going to say that
yeah i know that dude is just
like the quickest way for me to
explain that i'm pretty sure i'm going
to want to marry this girl did your
heart burst when you when you're with
her okay so how old are you man
i'm 19. 19. all right and
tell me where you met her um
actually uh online um she actually lives
in
washington okay so she's about two hours
away from me
and it's been a difficult five months
since the borders closed i haven't
really been able to see her much
but we're
finding ways to connect online and
do different things so it's
been good so what
what has tipped the balance for you what
has made you say
you know what this is it man i've had 19
years of riding solo and it's time to
time to get a partner and head off into
the wild west
what is it about those last five months
what is it about her
that makes you think yep i'm done my
search is over
um well
i don't know i've thought about it a lot
and for me it's just
a whole lot of things seem to be coming
together well
like pick him apart for me man yeah we
connect really well she kind of i'm
kind of a weird dude around here and a
lot of
and it's hard to find people that
actually like understand me
yeah i can see that it's like they're
few and far between and
she's one of those people that actually
gets me
she's kind hard working she's just
a wonderful person and it's somebody
i can see spending the rest of my life
with and so when you
so a being seen and heard for the first
time feels good doesn't it
yeah yeah and being valued for
the things that make you unique your
weird things i've got my plenty of weird
things
and um it feels good to be seen right
so yeah when you say hey i think you're
it
what is what's her response
uh she's pretty much in the same place i
am
okay like we're pretty much on the same
page with it
and so fast forward what do you think
this looks like
and not in a not in a fantasy world
or a mythological world like walk me
through the next few months of your life
what is that going to look like well um
at the when we first started dating we
kind of made the decision that around
one year
we would strongly consider if this was
going to be
like if we were going to get married or
if we were going to
end up going separate ways since we
don't want to date for 10 years and then
did not go anywhere really so
next few months is probably going to be
just more getting to know her trying to
figure out some more stuff in my own
life and
make sure that i'm kind of on the right
track
and then go from there i guess
i'm not sure all right so i'm gonna give
you some thoughts and some ideas
and what i'm not gonna do is say that
you're too young
and i'm not gonna say that you've only
known her for five months i'm not gonna
give you any of that traditional stuff
you're gonna get that from your friends
and your family and from the internets
and all that okay so i'm not gonna give
you those things
um 19 is young and i actually gave up a
full ride scholarship to one university
and went across the country to another
school because i met
a young girl when i was 18 and i wrapped
it up that was it for me i was done
and i ended up paying for school or for
a chunk of it
and it didn't work out but i ended up
meeting the person i was gonna marry at
that same place and so
all i had to say is i've made some big
life decisions when i was your age based
on this feeling
and this i just know this is it and um
so i'm not even gonna judge that
i'm gonna say man carry forward here's a
couple of things i want you to be
careful of and i want you to think
through okay
thing number one is there is a big
difference
between one year and ten years
and so i am really pushing back hard not
just with you but with
all of culture right now on this
obsession with an roi on friendship roi
meaning return on investment
you are my friend so that i can help you
can help me get a job
i am your friend because i'm networking
i want to be near you because you're
going to help me get where i want to go
um i want to have three friends that are
ahead of me and two friends that are
behind me
dude we have lost the art and the the
spiritual connection of just having
people in our lives
just because and so i want you to focus
deeply not on a time limit if it's not a
year man we gotta call it because
i think that's foolish and crazy my wife
and i dated five years we broke up a
whole bunch of times
okay um any sort of artificial
constraint like that just becomes that
an artificial constraint and you're
gonna find yourself making decisions
recklessly either i'm not a hundred
percent and so let's just call it and
you're gonna break up with a great what
someone who may be a lifelong friend
or someone who's gonna be your future
wife
just because you hit a deadline and i
just am not a fan of those things the
other side of that is
you're going to have to live in
proximity with each other
you're going to have to figure out a way
that you move to washington she moves to
vancouver that you all get in the same
area
and get some physical proximity over a
sustained period of time
where you get to see how there's some
great
research on disgust and relationships
one of the biggest predictors that a
relationship's not going to make it is
with
one of the other people one of the
partners is disgusted by the way they
move their mouth
or like when they open their mouth if
there's like little saliva strings when
they open it or something like that
there's this disgust when they see their
mouth kelly's face is like yeah
gosh and james just passed out on the on
the
on the board there but there's something
about you got to see her
okay um you've got to be in proximity
she's got to see you
and got to see how you all operate how
you walk how you treat people that
at the grocery store how you it's those
human things that you've got to see that
the internet just simply cannot give you
you can learn a lot about somebody but
it's generally a curated
experience online and there's nothing
that you can trade
for that connection and then here's the
final thing man
um
that one language that i'm in love
language is
is um i know
you're you're just saying hey that's the
easiest way i can just say man i'm all
i'm all in head over heels for this
this young lady and that's all good
but i want you to always remember this
love is a choice and it's a decision
it's a thing you do
every single day
so if you decide at some point in the
next
year two years whatever it is she is it
she's it and she decides that for you
i want you to know that that's not gonna
be a
um a
like there's not gonna be a music swell
and like you know there's not going to
be some james horner
like symphony playing up behind you and
suddenly you're going to stand taller
and you're going to have this romantic
that's just how it works you decide i'm
going to love you forever and you're
going to wake up the next day and say
i'm gonna love you forever and then four
months from then she's gonna get like a
real bad virus and be sick and be thrown
up and you're gonna wake up that morning
and say
i'm gonna love you forever and then
there's gonna be days that she just
walks in
and takes your breath away just stunning
and you're gonna say i'm gonna love you
forever and then there's gonna be days
that she comes in and you're like
i need you to leave because you are
making me angry and frustrated and i am
going to love you forever
and then there's gonna be days that she
hits you in the head with a with a
wiffle ball back because you deserve it
and you're going to have to say i'm
going to love you forever
this is a daily decision every single
day for the rest of your life
and so as you sw as you morph from these
feelings of desire i just want to be
with you i want to like
just be connected with you for the rest
of my life as that turns into
the day-to-day grind the day-to-day
safety as you learned
just each other's rhythms i want you to
then
focus on cultivating desire cultivating
being in love it's a
thing you're going to tell yourself
every day it's a thing you're going to
practice and that doesn't sound sexy and
they didn't talk about that in the
notebook
they didn't talk about that romeo and
juliet but it's the reality of living
with somebody
so all that to say 19 man you won the
lottery
good for you dude um you may just be
finding someone who sees you and loves
you for the first time and
high school sucks for 99.9 of people
because they have to pretend and play
and it's not real and it doesn't feel
right
um and so man i want to encourage you
lean in dude go for it at some point
you're gonna have to do your
goodwill hunting drive you're gonna have
to get an old crummy car and you have to
drive across the country and
move to be next to her and you're gonna
have to figure out life that way
so brother radish from delony baloney to
radish good for you
that's awesome